les admissions en réanimation continue
de grimper en région parisienne 1018
malades ont été admis en réanimation
pour moins de 1000 50 lits disponibles
en tout 3 1918 malades ont été admis en
réanimation dont 421 ces dernières 24
heures à dunkerque le confinement va
être prolongée de trois week-ends c'est
pour vous dire à quel point la situation
sanitaire elle continue de se dégrader
pour les alpes maritimes il faudra
encore attendre quelques jours pour
savoir si le confinement sera prolongée
ou pas la décision sera sûrement prise
demain lors du conseil de défense
sanitaire
d'autres mesures pourraient être
annoncées lors de la traditionnelle
conférence de presse du gouvernement ce
jeudi 11 mars
concernant l'île de france et paris est
bien le confinement ne serait pas
d'actualité selon jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé écoutez le
le confinement de l'île de france n'est
pas d'actualité
l'ile-de-france est probablement la
région que nous surveillons le plus nous
mobilisons l'ensemble des lignes et des
personnels disponibles
nous sommes en très forte tension et
nous suivons la situation jour après
jour à entendre jérôme mais on
pourrait croire que la situation
épidémique est sous contrôle
1 mais les chiffres qu'on voit le
contraire ils ne sont pas bons en île de
france par exemple le toit d'incidence
dépasse le seuil de 250 dans chacun et
des huit départements franciliens la
semaine dernière est les niveaux les
plus élevés sont atteints en seine saint
denis et dans le val de marne et le
variant britannique est majoritaire dans
les hôpitaux
la tension est telle que la rs d'île de
france a donné l'ordre ferme dans les
hôpitaux de déprogrammer 40 % de leur
activité
medica pour justement pouvoir accueillir
les patients qu'aux vide
le gouvernement l'a dit depuis le début
il compte sur la vaccination mais pour
le moment force est de constater et bien
ok la situation et continue de se
dégrader dans le pays malgré les
promesses ambitieuses de l'exécutif la
menace d'un confinement le week-end
plane à nouveau sur certaines régions
si les hôpitaux sont à nouveau
bordés est bien la capitale pourrait se
retrouver sur le banc des confiné